[Music]
let's look into these complex hybrids a
little bit how to actually do them it's
the kind of hybrid that Andy a Nick
Schmidt showed me years and years ago in
Thailand where one poised doing an
isolation and the other poised doing a
little extension so the hands move
together in same direction same time
while the poi are in split time so to me
the hybrid is combining split time poi
with same time hands or you could do the
same time play with split time hands the
trick is the isolation poi is going to
be the one inside your arms so I've got
one poi in between my arms the other poi
outside my arms and the good way to do
it is just practice a bunch so I'm gonna
take my right hand and I'm gonna keep
practicing going from just spinning to
how I kind of take the weight off and
then chase after it to do an isolation
so I do that for awhile it's practice
spinning in that transition into
isolation and the other pole goes from
spinning and just into extension
practicing independently at first
feeling okay how do you do that then and
it's this is an annoying one I don't
know an easy way for this one it's that
feeling of that extension being the
thing that chases this one around the
top which makes an isolation and it
might take a while before you make the
breakthrough and you go earth and pow
this extension is now driving the other
isolation other things you can try you
can try just holding that point first
imagining it and going okay okay and
imagining this is an extension and
you're using the extension to drive the
isolation and for some of you it might
help where you try a Rob Thorburn and I
think mention this to me that you make a
little short short poi and you can try
using that to drive the isolation and
slowly you work your way up to the ploy
being the same length from there it's
just a lot of its isolation isolation
just takes so much drilling it's not a
weak thing it's like months and months
and months or a couple of years they're
really good smooth everything is
oppositely true on the other side or
this it'll be my left paw going
backwards in isolation my right boy
doing an extension I start just spinning
and then the same thing the extension
kind of derives around
derives the isolation so to speak we and
from there I've been playing with and no
I something the practices connecting
them where I'm passing through briefly
the backward isolation forward isolation
backward isolation forward isolation
backward forward and that leads just
kind of this cool movement where the
hands can stay together and the hands
moving same time with the Poyer and
split time and I like the illusion of
that and you can play it all around your
body I can put instead of between my
arms to my arms put one behind me or
both behind me and then I start having
this kind of cool meltdown ii effect
and the basic skill set of all of this
if I were to reverse my arms that comes
back to this double triquetra buzzsaw
fountain and know I'm no longer
technically doing this complex hybrid
when I do that but the skill set of
complex hybrids spills back in the vest
because isolation always spills into a
teaspoon yeah so something to play with
it's a rainy cold morning here at the
vibin studio but I wanted to make poi
video as always keeps in the requests
it's been great to get requests so I'm
building a little list that's gonna keep
me going for a while of stuff to explore
and I'm thinking I'm gonna try some real
of some more live streams because I did
one for an off festival in Russia and I
went really well so I think I'm gonna do
an hour-long livestream on rhythm and
musicality with boy I hope that sounds
fun because it sounds fun to me
[Music]